current trends are very clear first of
all it's easier and easier for companies
to gather data so there's this big data
movement and that doesn't appear to be
slowing down anytime soon
number two currently advertisers can
already engage in personalized
advertising or dynamic creatives the
underlying idea is that well since I
know some information about this
consumer what he or she likes to buy
what types of preferences they have
maybe this is based on browsing history
maybe purchase history maybe zip code
all these things are observable online
today why don't I use that information
to cater my message to tailor my message
to that particular user and so we wanted
to understand where we had it where we
will be in say 10 years time there's a
reason that advertisers will do what
they're doing and there's a reason
consumers will buy or not and so game
theory allows us to incorporate consumer
incentives and advertisers incentives
into a model so the model is very very
simple first of all the advertiser can
collect information about consumer then
the advertiser can send a message that
can rely on that information or not and
the consumer can decide whether to buy
or not for example so this could be
anything could be a dealership trying to
attract the consumer for a test drive it
could be a realtor trying to attack a
tracked person to visit an open house or
it could be an online ad trying to get
me to the store and try a new pair of
sneakers the first thing that we're
identifying and exploring is the fact
that by giving information were lending
ourselves to be targeted and you know in
a sense that information can be used
against us by the other party
a big question in marketing is that of
truth in advertising right that's
central to marketing
can we trust sellers and what they claim
and even the Federal Trade Commission
allows advertisers to what they engage
in what they call a persuasive puffery
to puff up their attributes to claim
that they have the best burgers in town
or that they have you know the the most
trendy shirts or you know whatever you
want when in reality this is always a
little hard to judge these are
subjective claims but if they're you
know sort of reasonably sort of expected
claims as expected the exaggerations
well that turns out to be legal that
creates a very interesting interaction
with personalized advertising because if
I have that leeway to convey the exact
attributes that you care about I can
customize my message to make it the most
appealing to you as possible right at
the same time as consumers understand
that this is happening that's the
genesis of the credibility issue they
understand that the advertising has that
the ads have been tailored to their
tastes and so now that creates a
mistrust from consumers between
consumers and and advertisers they
understand that advertisers have that
leeway to customize their message to
become to make them the most attractive
possible and so the sometimes reported
low credibility that advertisers already
have with consumers is in peril of
becoming even less credible
so in an age where data is almost free
and it's becoming so easy to collect
data how should we think about what is
best for advertisers should they get
better data or not and what is best for
consumers for companies best practices
are to always inform customers of the
data that they are collecting about
consumers and that is a good thing for
companies it's we usually think that's
you know why would companies want to
disclose that well it turns out
consumers will appreciate the fact that
there's clear privacy policies and
there's clear data disclosure policies
in you know companies like Google
Facebook Amazon now have that type of
information and you can access your
personal information that they're
collecting about you on the consumer
front should I share my personal
information with advertisers or not well
it turns out we find the following
effect if these are mainstream
preferences like I would like a spacious
house or a family-friendly car those are
sort of mainstream preferences lots of
people have those preferences it turns
out we don't benefit quite a lot from
from giving off those in that
information if anything we can get sales
people now pitching us back our tastes
right however if our tastes are very
specific okay if there's something we
really would like to find or we would
like to be found by so maybe I like this
particular type or genre of comic book
or this particular type of music that
very few people like or there's very few
artists playing then I would like to be
found by those people and so those are
the situations where I would like to
give off it from information and and
disclose my likes and dislikes are in
settings where my tastes are really not
representative but they're really sort
of niche type tastes
in a sense an ironic finding of our
paper is that better information can be
worse for advertisers which is really
surprising
it's a perverse effect I get better
information about consumers this is all
what managers talk about sort of this
big data revolution and I can become
worse off because consumers are
understanding that that firms are taking
advantage of these data to personalize
their messages to target them and
they're not likely to respond in a
positive way to these types of ads and
kind of consumers and firms really have
only two ways to go about this and
particularly managers can either decide
not together too much data about
consumers which is hard to to impose or
at the very least disclose how those
that are being used and so if I'm seeing
an ad if I'm targeted with an ad I would
like to know why I'm getting this ad
getting rid of that uncertainty for
consumers is useful because now they can
make the call they can understand well
ok this firm has this data about me they
want to rank recommend me this product
but it's up to me whether I want to pay
attention to that call to action or not